Tonight, the top U.S.
general, Mark Milley, is giving his take
on another chapter
in the Trump
classified documents investigation.
This was reporting
that CNN broke last week
that the former
president recorded
was recorded in July 2021
indicating that
he had a classified Pentagon document
pertaining to a potential attack on Iran.
And implying
that it would counter
what his top general,
Mark Milley, was saying.
Those comments were apparently
in response to a New Yorker
article
saying that Milley had warned
Trump against striking Iran.
Reportedly telling Trump, quote,
You're going to have a f ing war.
Senator Lieberman spoke
exclusively with General Mark Milley,
who was only willing to say
this about that investigation.
The former president suggested
in a book by Mark Meadows
that it was your desire to attack Iran.
And he was saying no.
Is that what happened?
Well, I'll be
entirely inappropriate or thankfully,
I prepared to comment on that.
It'd be
entirely inappropriate for me
to comment on the ongoing
federal investigation,
and I'm not going to do that now.
So not even to clarify
what happened there.
No, I think it's inappropriate.
There's an ongoing federal investigation,
and I'm not going to comment
one way or another
on any of the issues concerning that.
Let's get more insight
tonight from former Trump
national security adviser John Bolton.
And thank you, Ambassador,
for being here.
You heard from General Milley.
They're weighing in.
We do know
from our reporting
that he has spoken
to investigators in this case.
But when it comes to this document
that Trump allegedly had on plans
to potentially strike Iran.
Do you know
which which document
Trump could have been holding in his
hands during this recording?
Well, I don't
I don't think
there's any way of knowing and
given Trump's propensity to overstate
things.
It's entirely possible
he was holding in his hand
something like
the lunch menu
from the Bedminster Grill that day
and that he was embellishing on what
what a document
that Mark Milley might have prepared
would say.
So this goes
to a pretty fundamental point.
I don't have any doubt
there are very sensitive
documents involved here.
But until you actually see them,
I think it's important
not to kind of overhype
what what may be at stake here,
particularly with Trump,
who is propensity to bluster.
There's actually a better word for that
I won't use on TV,
but his propensity to bluster
is unending.
Well,
I think there's concern from prosecutors
here, though,
because they clearly
want to know more about this.
I mean, they brought the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
in to talk about it.
And, of course,
we don't actually know
which document Trump
was holding at that time,
if he was simply referencing
this document.
But what our reporting did show
is that the Justice
Department wanted this document
and they sent a subpoena
they made clear to Trump's attorneys,
I was told
that they wanted this document
specifically that he was talking about
on tape.
But Trump's attorneys
could not locate the document
to produce it.
So if he was holding that document
and they were unable to find it
and there is a document
related to Iran out there,
how much does that concern you
about how it could compromise the U.S.
national security
Well, if it were an actual
document that the Pentagon produced as
as a war plan, that would be one thing.
If it's simply Trump making it up
as he goes along.
That could explain
why they can't find it,
because it never existed.
I mean, the other explanation
is he destroyed it.
And that would be a very serious matter
because it would show,
I think, clearly
a guilty
intent that he had a
highly classified document
at The idea that that
that you can take, though,
the real official documents
the Pentagon works on
and kind of spread them around
even to the president,
I would be very surprised at that.
They are understandably kept
very tightly held,
infrequently taken away from the Pentagon
and usually removed
from the Situation Room
or the Oval Office
with great care
when the people
who brought them over leave.
And I should note that
you also have a level of concern here.
The Justice Department
charged a suspected Iranian operative
last year for allegedly
plotting to assassinate you.
But on this front of
when it comes to the relationship
that Trump had with General Milley,
what were your observations
about Trump's views
toward Chairman Milley?
Well, when
I was at the White House,
this was in the period where
where the successor to General
Joe Dunford,
who was the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
at the beginning
of the administration, was going on.
And my own personal view
was that Mark Milley
should be chairman of the Joint Chiefs.
It happened
that the Trump agreed with that
and appointed him.
And I think
at the beginning
he was enthusiastic
that it was a good choice.
And I certainly believe that at the time
I was gone,
I think when a lot of this
interesting material happened.
But it's obvious that relationship
between Milley and Trump
soured as Trump's relationship
with so many other people soured.
As we see these investigations ramp up or
we're going to wait
to see
what the special counsel
does on this document investigation.
Trump is still the frontrunner
for the Republican nomination
for president.
You've said you're
considering a 2024 run.
Have you made a decision on that yet?
No, I haven't.
I want to
I want to see what what happens
with some of the other announcements.
I would not do this frivolously or merely
to criticize
Trump's performance in office,
although that would be,
I think, an extensive job to do.
It would be
with the serious intent to win.
I think it's critical
for the Republican Party
absolute critical
and for the country as well
that Trump did not get our nomination.
I think in a race against Biden,
as unpopular as Biden is.
Trump might well win.
So I think this is a serious matter
that the Republicans
are going to have to deal with.
I wouldn't
count on a day of sex
and a
like an indictment
in the classified documents case.
To save us on this.
Knowing Trump,
he may well turn it into an asset.
How soon do you think you need
to make a decision on like that?
Like on this,
since we're seeing how big
the field is getting
Well, frankly, that's
another consideration
if there's
a small army of people
wandering around seeking the nomination.
I don't think there would be a case
that I would be adding anything.
But but I think it's still early.
I think this is a very strange cycle.
And I think honestly,
in the next 90 days,
it's a
it's a two man race
between Governor DeSantis and Trump.
I think
knowing Trump
as I do,
that he will unload
on DeSantis unceasingly.
He's already started.
And I think Governor DeSantis
has got to come back with his case
as to
why Trump's
not qualified to be president.
And that's really
a marker for everybody else
who might get in.
You're not going to get
the Republican nomination
by picking away at the other opponents.
You're going to win the nomination
by taking Trump on directly
and beating him.
Well, they're not really taking
Trump out directly.
I mean,
we saw eight of the candidates
Trump in the night in Iowa
over the weekend,
and none of them would really directly
say his name when they were on stage.
Do you think it's a mistake
for candidates like Governor DeSantis
to not directly
criticize Trump in this race?
100%.
This is not
an issue
about philosophy
because Trump has no philosophy
and it's not really an issue
about his personality or his temperament.
It's about his competence
to be president, which he does not have.
And I think
unless you make that point
effectively to voters and ignore the £800
gorilla,
it's impossible to make that case.
So I think the person
who ultimately wins
the Republican nomination
is the person who beats Trump.
And as you say and I agree,
I don't think anybody has stepped up
to that role.
Maybe Chris Christie.
Well, God bless him. If he does.
But if he doesn't, somebody needs to.
My in my case, though,
it would be not just to do that,
but to win the nomination.
We'll see what you decide ultimately.
I know you were listening
to the top of the show
as we were talking about this
new CNN reporting on investigators
looking into a pool
that was drained at Mar a Lago
and then flooded a room
that has the computer servers
that store the surveillance footage
that we know prosecutors have subpoenaed.
Of course,
still a lot of questions about that.
But what was your reaction
to hearing that
Well, I think the prosecutors are right
to be suspicious
of of Trump
and his capacity to obstruct justice.
This particular episode Frank, frankly,
struck me as a little Rube
Goldberg like
but but not beyond
the realm of the possible.
I don't remember the geography
of the architecture
enough to understand
how draining the pool
would have flooded this room.
But but it's look,
you've got to pursue every lead in a case
that's serious.
There's no doubt about it.
It may turn out not to represent anything
or it may we don't know.
There's a lot we don't know.
And that may be part of it.
Yeah. A lot of questions remain.
Ambassador John Bolton,
thank you for your time tonight.